taste buds they come to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man com okay time to t a s d
e buds or time to welcome to screw it's
time to taste though it's time to taste
bud time to taste buds taste buddies
welcome to the show uh we're here with a
special guest a dear friend of yours yes
my my dear friend Josh Nasser who is a
lovely human being a comedian in from
the west coast and a like a one of the
biggest
ticktockers Tik Tock you have the most
successful I've never seen anyone that
has as many views as you be honest with
you yeah I was waiting to jump in with
the T I really want to do it because
I've watched other episodes and and you
started right out and I missed it and I
feel like I we run that back but we
don't have to we don't have to edit it
here but we're going to do it again just
for you we can do it again ready ready
time two no no no I'll say the right way
hey tties welcome to t a s e buds buds
well yeah well you know what you got to
practice his spelling
before I was so excited um so so uh Josh
I apologize that I was unaware of your
Tik Tok status yeah but you have 7.5
million it's across all of them now I
started during the pandemic holy crap
yeah so I mean you were you were TV host
on television your comic but I mean how
long you been a comic I did comedy for
20 years I was on Sons of Anarchy I
played a cop I hosted shows for ESPN but
I was just like working but making rent
but not but making you know and then
during the pandemic I was like man I'm
sick of this and I just I put hidden
cameras in my car and I started driving
up and down the same street and just
started filming I didn't how to edit um
and I would literally pull over on the
side of the road with like helicopters
above me because of the riots and
everything and be editing and as soon as
I got 100,000 views I'd shoot another
video and I just kept going and going
and going and now it's billions of views
did you also just semi- recently start
the YouTube channel and and and how many
subscribers do you have I got uh one
point almost 1.2 million I did it in 10
months jesus.2 but I'm I'm Relentless
like it my I was telling you before my
mental health this I wake up I check the
numbers I was just editing before I mean
it's it's not a game I'm in therapy
hardcore therapy because of social
mediaob it's a job the app suck the apps
right Facebook just said hey we owe you
last day of the pay period they go oh we
got a glitch sorry we we're going to
give you n there a worldwide glitch you
can look it up they're not giving you
the rest of the money no they're not
giving it to you and then you message
them and they go I'm sorry it's our
policy not to let you know what policy
you broke but here's our policies so
those are the kind of things that that
happen yeah wow that's can you can you
litigate I me it's YouTube it's Facebook
it's Facebook but I mean this is what we
go through as creators is not a class
action people are talking
this is literally what's happening as we
were filming this right now that's
what's happening right now people are
like Yo dude cuz this happened all over
the world they just go we made a glitch
you just got this news yeah and now you
have to do this podcast yeah you just
lost yeah like that we were all excited
hey this is amazing I made money oh my
God you know yeah what is what is why is
their glitch your problem what are they
saying the glitch is that they they
never that they don't say that's the
problem they won't say so they just said
we had a glitch that sound Shady to me
and by the way it's definitely Shady by
the way they told us on the very last
day of the pay period yeah oh we we
didn't know is there a a right now is
there a Facebook Uprising going on by
all the content creators people are
talking about it I know Fortune Magazine
has done an article on it Yahoo finance
done an article I mean it's like what am
I gonna do though like I mean it's but
that's that's crazy dude that's that's
like the norm oh also right now they owe
me Jesus God just go there's there's uh
there's there's a problem we're not sure
your identity we need to verify your
identity so we're going to hold your
money so the the the moral is you know
get billions of views yeah and uh then I
don't we got Jes God man that is insane
that is insane I mean look we're in
we're in a very very dangerous time
right now with um with the
corporatization of of these things and
and we're all participating in it and
then we're all at the mercy of it h so
we're contributing to the monster
because we're all addicted to the
monster right but then these kinds of
things happen they all have these
loopholes and these shadow policies that
they can you know they can they can
shroud everything they do and say yeah
you sound like the smart one thank you
sometimes they have these loopholes and
Shadow policies that they can shroud
everything they do that's a very that's
a very U smart can I be honest I was
proud of it as it was coming out of my
mouth yeah F good shroud put me on top
but what uh what I mean that's the thing
it like like like Netflix just did this
thing where they came out and they said
we're we're redefining what counts as a
view and I was like oh my God that's
what YouTube does too there's
definitions of what counts as a view
like a sustaining the the time exactly
but how funny that Netflix makes the
announcement that they are making this
new definition they released the
statement at midnight during the writer
strike where a writer strike is all
about the residuals and it's like oh wow
that's shitty and it's just like you
know the all the stuff with the
streamers it was the most thing in in
ever okay we don't release our numbers
though yeah suits was that had 12.8
billion minutes watched and from what I
heard I could be wrong the writers of
that residuals they got
$3,000 wow yeah do you have you seen
this show Suits I've been seeing it I
thought it was a new show it's not do
you know there's nine Seasons they
pulled it from the USA Network I know
about the show I know how old it is and
I know that it was very popular it in an
almost cult way no it was just the
people never heard of it not a ton of
people watched it well I I'm wrong did
nine Seasons a ton of people watched it
but my point is is like in a mainstream
sense I don't think every I don't think
the average person now people are
watching it since they dropped on
Netflix I I literally I stayed up till 4
in the morning for the last week I'm I'm
adct people love it that's what I was
going to say the people that love it are
obsessed with it it's the best TV show
I've ever seen Donna I love you Harvey
Spector all of them but it's a it's a
show on USA that doesn't limit it or
hinder it in any way I'm telling you
this show is is amazing you know who
loves it rick Glassman was talking my
ear off about it when he was on the show
we when we walked yeah I don't know he
walked for a while he he was talking my
ear off about how much he loves suits
and I go my friend
Roland Roland I love the name Roland
Roland was OA the OA work Ser was the OA
Booker um and uh but he he uh he was
when this show was on he was like he
wouldn't shut up about it so these folks
right here I mean I'm sure they had nine
seasons of Megan Marco's on it yes it's
the show that launched and she's a great
actress like great holds her own goes
toe-to-toe with these heavyweight actors
so these people nine Seasons they
probably got their paycheck but like now
that it's
exploding they don't participate in the
sale for to Netflix exploding because
it's exploding via streaming and that's
the problem wow um I'm sure it'll help
them in other endeavors though hopefully
I hope so word yeah I love your vocab so
I when I met Josh when did I when did we
meet like I don't know when like ComiCon
we met ComiCon but which one San Diego
yeah through Dana Moon another comedian
our friend hi Dan oh I love Dana yeah
she's the best I like her uh uh Social
Media stuff yeah she does characters
yeah they're really funny Elon Musk just
retweeted her no didn't give her credit
no put retweeted her one of her
characters and didn't give her credit
but isn't it I don't know what happened
I don't know how did it but isn't it her
account there for I don't how it was it
was it was her face was her video Elon
Musk and then she did a video do you
think he me do you think he meant well
though in retweeting her I don't know
he's he's the guy he's the main guy he's
not supposed to do that I mean yeah it
was all over but no but it's I I'm
trying to just do the math I don't know
if it was like 10 years ago whatever it
was yeah and you look similar to how you
look now but I remember the first time
that you revealed to me that you had an
Ed Hardy
past I was the worst I drove a Hummer I
had a Jaguar with
spinners I mean this complaining about
money over here he's driving Jaguars do
do you get that from wait wait wait at
the time I wasn't doing comedy I this is
true I sold frozen meat door too I was a
door to- door meat salesman butcher box
baby yeah I sold meat door to door but
you weren't you like I was the The
Prodigy of I was I sold the Reeves hey
how you doing huh was this your lady no
this is just my friend shishi she was a
news the belt if we can zoom in on that
belt that's those studs right there I
almost felt like I I was like I thought
I knew you we all have this and you were
living in La I was living in La only in
La yeah can you walk around dress like
that where people will not openly make F
of you look look look look at the spray
tan how you doing huh is that a diamond
earring in the right I adopt cubic
zarconi really never really had a lot of
money all the money I made from selling
meat I was spending on my Ed Hardy wow
yeah I mean this what the other one is a
t do you have one in there a t that
one's not that bad that that just looks
like the earring look at this and you at
the chain I double chains oh my God
double chains and look at that look at
that uh stitching In Those Jeans yeah
lagona Beach jeans is that that was that
was the thing at the time my buddy was
on a show called sunset Tan he owned the
company and we would go to Vegas and
hang out at the Palms and that was the
time you know nightclub how old are you
were in these photos um 30 okay yeah
that's good at Hardy age oh I was the it
was the best I never I never did it the
D at Hardy type of thing me Nei or True
Religion no I never did that me neither
I was never into any of it how would you
now 522 tomorrow I'll be birthday
tomorrow oh happy birthday happy
birthday B I'm going to be with s on my
birthday you look amazing such great
yeah right Botox juviderm wrestling I
get facials really yeah I got to talk to
you about that oh really yeah off camera
on camera uh both okay off
okay Josh so we're doing this battle
today Josh flew in from La he's actually
staying with me a bit but he had to he
had to get a hotel last night he's
coming with me tonight to stay at the
house for few days and he just texted me
what uh what happened in his hotel and
for me it's my worst
nightmare he peeled off the sheets wait
hold on so when I leave a hotel I feel
bad for the house cleaner so I
completely clean everything up I put
everything in a pile I separate and I
take off the sheets and it was a huge
urine stain
look at that vict not just not just a
huge urine stain that's really gross
yeah I will
say no way there's nothing redeeming
about this nothing wait I have a
question though that means that like
that wasn't cleaned cuz they would stay
they would throw that out they're hiding
it but I think they I was going to say I
think they cleaned it but it might still
be stained and they kept it like that
look at V Shake in her head V knows a
peace thing when she SE one clean how do
you clean the urine maybe if maybe
like I've had mattresses that over time
like from sweating like they'll get
those brown stains on them I I started
using mattress covers because pillows
will get the stain you use the that look
I'm not saying you shouldn't be
horrified that could just be a stain
that is clean no no no it was it was
urine and the whole place smelled like
urine oh well then then you got then you
got pee on your hands yeah yeah I did
there was cigarette Burns in the
pillowcase like it was I was like hey
I'll just go a cheap hotel in wway New
Jersey I don't know where I didn't even
know Facebook sent you down to the slums
dude they took that six figure paycheck
away can't sleeping in
pee that what's crazy to me is the
brightness of yellow that has a fresh
pece yeah that's that's fresh bro
because over time Pete I don't think it
looks like that I called to the front
desk and the guy goes yes we know that
we have this problem we have uh mattress
pads they're on order we know that we
have this problem we know that we have
this problem we have mattress p it's not
just your room they're on order every
mattress is pissed up yeah um so I
didn't want to lose my did they allow
pets the guy doesn't go the guy doesn't
go how about we give you your money back
sorry about that this was the thing the
problem will be resolved once after you
leave so I didn't want to lose my
because look I just started doing social
media my social media is all happy I'm
happy guy so I went downstairs and I was
breathing in the elevator I'm like I'm
not should lost your on the
mattress I wait a minute deserv so this
is from when last night oh but wait you
what do you mean you just started oh I
got thrown off when you said I just
started doing social media I'm starting
to get a little bit recognized oh
it's you know I'm like known as nice guy
I don't want to like all of a sudden I
don't need this out on the internet I
don't need any problems you know right
so I was like let me just not create a
let me not burn this place to the ground
did you make a video about this I I no I
just took pictures and by the way it's
crazy when I woke up and or when I saw
that I I go I can't wait to show you I
thought of you oh thank
you I don't know why not you I got
people often think of me with excrement
different kinds the uh maybe because
you'd be salty about it I just thought
well I I actually have a similar story I
stayed stay at this hotel and I pissed
on the mattress yeah the night two
nights ago now the uh I I actually think
I told the story on the Pod but I did a
road trip last summer because I bought a
car in LA and I drove it home and I went
through Utah and everybody was like you
better get a room before you get out
there and I was like I'll be fine and at
like I'm not even kidding man it was
like 2: a.m. I was in Utah and I
couldn't find a room anywhere and I was
like ah it sucked and I found this
little
roadside Motel I was like whatever this
will do I don't even try that I just
sleep in the car and I I was afraid to
sleep in the car cuz I didn't know where
I was and I was like what if God forbid
I get murdered or something I don't know
you know yeah soft top vehicle I was
scared you know so anyway yeah you're
going to get murdered in Utah no one's
going to say anything either yeah right
so beautiful you have just as much
chance getting murdered in the roadside
motel but sure sure uh you know but I I
I went into the room and the sheets I
can't the sheets had blood stains on
them oh and they were still reddish
which means they were newer oh and I put
on a hoodie that I didn't care about and
shorts I didn't care about and then I
laid towels down on it and I slept like
this oh and I slept like this and when I
woke up I threw the hoodie and shorts in
the trash and I and I left and that was
it wow I just I wish I could have seen
that moment that you saw the blood like
that whole I took videos of it and I
wrote I wrote a whole
like did you report it to like whoever
you rented through no dude this place
was I mean this you think this this
place was I mean I don't know what this
looked like from the outside this place
you know dude no this place from the
outside was nice it they they CED as a
business center and you had business
Suites and it was you know a gy no this
was not this was like this was like open
hallway you walk to your door there's a
literal key yeah like this was Bates
Motel type literally the way that's laid
out yeah it was like that I see blood
piss on a mattress like that excuse me
the next stop is the presidential
suite well what if you can't find the
president IAL
Suite what do you mean what do you mean
the presidential suite yeah what does
that mean you like they're going to
upgrade me to the best thing they have
immed check that for piss and blood if
there's piss and blood there buddy they
don't have a presidential suite I got
news for you yeah they don't yeah
lawsuit yeah I stayed in a place in uh
on the road uh I was I I don't want to
say the city because I don't want to
blow up the
club because I like the
club but I was in a hotel and it was
supposed to be like this cute rustic
like historic whatever and I called my
manager and I was like I when I got in
the room I called him I go dude what
what is this and he was like what and I
go dude I swear to God if if I can't get
into another room I'm going home I'm not
doing the show this is disgusting there
was black mold on one of the walls there
was uh pubic visible pubic hair uh in
the like on the like hair on the bed
there was hair on on the soap dish in
the bathroom yeah like cake to it that's
that's wild there were stains everywhere
I it smelled like pee and the hotel was
like oh my God we are so sorry we're so
embarrassed this was a mistake the room
wasn't clean we're so sorry and they
sent me to another room and the other
room was pristine and I was like okay
okay all right like I I feel like a
cleaning person got fired over that
probably right right right yeah I've had
some nightmares I had like four or five
nightmares experience one time in not
black mold on the walls but there was
like I had a hole in one of a hole in
the sheetrock in one of the my hotels in
Iowa and I got there and it like it was
carpeted and it was damp and it smelled
like that musky smell there a hole in
the wall and there was no other places
to stay and I was like this is insane so
I went to like a a CVS or whatever and I
bought like a uh disposable ponchos and
I just opened them up and slept on the
plastic it was terrible and and it was a
noise you know when you turn on that
like the water sometimes and it'll
squeeze squeal or squeak and it like
kind of
stops that was happening and I was like
oh I guess it's someone's taking a
shower at the water and I waited like a
half hour I didn't stop and I called
downstairs and I said there's a noise
that's like it's not stopping I thought
it was the water and she goes what room
are you in I told her and she said oh
that room does
that so apparently we've all had this I
mean we this is like the nor I I won't
to one time we when we first started out
we were in a Red Roof in like someone
booked this in a Red Roof in and we were
going in and I was like guys there's a
there's a holidaying across the street
I'm hesitant about this Red Roof in and
they were all like nah let's just stay
here let's just stay here I'm like it
was across the highway though I was like
I'm going to Across the highway
right now right he goes look why don't
we go in check it out and let and then
we'll decide so we go in I was with Q at
the time Q goes into his room open door
outside with the key like same thing he
goes into his room I go into my room I
look I'm like this is just not for me I
walk out he's holding a crack pipe there
was a crack pipe in his room he's
holding it it's in a cup it's in a
plastic cup amazing yeah
a crack pipe he walked in and found a
crack pipe which means someone smok
crack pip crack there right but which
also means that the person who clean the
room just didn't see the crack pipe or
didn't care about the crack pipe or just
left it for the next person yeah that's
somebody that might be that might be a
clean person going I'm tired of this
I'm not I'm not touching a crack
pipe I don't care if they fire me that's
why I clean the room before I leave
because I feel so bad for the
housekeeper I neat up I don't I don't
strip the bed I don't want to know
what's you're opening that's what you
did you opened the can of worms there I
take the the soap out that I've used
everything's in a pile like they walk in
cuz I do the pile I put I do the pile of
my towels and I make the bed like like
like I just put the pillows back and
flatten out everything I make sure all
my garbage is in the garbage pil I
vacuum no
no I also V vacuum they don't come in
once for my whole stay either oh you
don't let them come in neither I don't
have housekeeping come in once so I go
in and I leave I leave with minimal work
for the housekeeping staff to do and
they never have to come in during this
day I'm a pretty I'm a pretty good hotel
guest in that yeah I do I don't let him
in either that's interesting to know
unless it's like a week or more long
vacation and that place is very nice
otherwise even then sometimes I'm just
like I don't need new sheets like I'm
here a few day like you know like I
don't need anybody in here the only
thing I've ever had to reup on is like
sometimes like they won't give me enough
towels or something and I'll use the
same towel too by the way I I'll use a
bath towel three four showers I don't
care I use the same like that wait at
the home you won't do thatuh wait at
home how long do you use the same towel
home or on the road I I'll go at least
three showers one towel at least when
you're drying off you're clean I do too
yeah it's so hot in here can we open the
door without that you're hot yeah I'm
very hot breezily cool right now yeah
well you're you're in you want to sit
you want to switch that's not it's
sitting here so you're getting like the
tons no I don't want to do that to you
you're not doing anything to me let's
switch we've switched before let's
switch really are you sure yeah because
you're going to be you're going to be
cooler and then you don't have to open
the door okay well I appreciate that you
sacrifice your own comfort for mine and
that is going to be noted and it's not
going to be forgotten I got to tell you
I already felt the change in Crossing
into this hemisphere it's hot right yeah
there was something cre something
creaked up as I was walking into it I
was actually over there like I might
pass
out yeah there is a warmth on over here
I don't know what it is I could open it
oh the secret is do it ruin the magic is
a door here
leave that shut leave that shut if you
if you don't cool off then open it again
folks let's talk about first Leaf first
Leaf is great for the summertime the
best time summertime wine delivery yes
there's going to be something fun going
on throughout the summer okay pretty
much every week in barbecues and pool
parties and family events and camping
trips whatever it is for all those
occasions I like to make sure I've got
great wine at the ready and that's why
summer is actually the perfect time to
join first Leaf wine club this is a club
where it's super easy to get
personalized wine boxes delivered on
schedule whatever your schedule is and
since you get to choose the day your
shipment comes you can go out and have
all your fun without worrying about
missing that delivery and they're world
class ones as well yes yes so if you
want to get started with first Leaf all
you have to do is answer some quick
questions about your likes and your
dislikes on their website and uh their
expert team will select a customized
assortment of worldclass wines based on
your preferences yes and every selection
is backed by first least 100%
satisfaction guarantee and I will say
this they got the sparkling they got the
Reds they got nice whites but they also
have Joey Ros yes yeah I don't know if
you all know Joey Ros Joe used to drink
Rosé so much his nickname was Joey Ros
yes yes that is true uh I love a rosé in
the summertime I also though like a nice
crisp red that's that's nice and cool in
the summertime a nice Pino or something
like that uh anyway I love this because
anytime I need wine it's always looking
and I realize I'm out of it in the
moment that I need it so to make sure
you've got great wine when you want it
this summer you got to try first Leaf
just head over to First leaf.com
tastebuds to sign up and you'll get your
first six hand curated bottles for just
$44.95 go to go to trir leaf.com go to
trir leaf.com
tastebuds that's t r y fi R SLE e a.com
tastebuds to get your first six bottles
for under $8 a bottle and trir leaf.com
that's trir leaf.com tastebuds Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit they're ready to help you fuel up
fast with Chef prepared dietition
approved ready to eat meals delivered
straight to your door you're going to
save time you're going to eat well
you're going to stay on track with the
healthy lifestyle I just ate Factor
today I had the turkey chili it was
delicious I love Factor you get it you
throw it in the microwave it's already
cooked 2 minutes boom every meal ranges
in the sort of 600 calorie range I say 4
50 to 650 from my experience it's just
great folks you're going to get to
choose from 34 plus weekly flavor packed
dietician approved meals they're ready
to eat as I said in 2 minutes if you're
too busy running around during the day
to think about lunch keep your energy up
with this lunch to go these are
effortless wholesome meals like grain
bowls and salad Toppers that are ready
to eat when you're on the go no
microwave even required for those I love
it okay with Factory you can rest
assured you're making a sustainable
choice we offset 100% of their delivery
emissions Source 100% renewable
electricity for our production sites and
offices and they feature sustainably
sourced Seafood in their meals head to
factor meals.com
tastebuds and use the code tastebuds 5
to get 50% off that's code tastebuds 5@
Factor meals.com
tastebuds 5 to get 50% off folks Joe D
Rosa here I am hitting the big open road
this this fall with I Never Promised You
a Rose Garden the tour coming to a bunch
of cities bunch of shows excited to see
you out there September 16th avenol New
Jersey September 21st through the 23rd
Toronto uh September 29th through
October 1st I'll be at skankfest not
doing the hour there but I'll be there
and I hope to see you uh November 11th
Philadelphia Pennsylvania theater of the
Living Arts November 17th Pittsburgh PA
nov nober 18th Buffalo New York November
30th Denver Colorado December 1st
Phoenix Arizona December 3rd Salt Lake
City my gosh my gosh my gosh we have so
much going on and this just in October
28th here in New York City at Arleen's
grocery Sala windfall first live show in
20 years people who's joining us well
may baby esoteric a DJ s larace is going
to be joining us who else is joining us
the stumble bombs who else is joining us
we'll see you in hell live it's going to
be a Halloween bash more acts are being
announced it is an event an event an
event October 28th we want to see you
there and before you come make sure you
cop that new salsa windfall album
artificial birth available on all
streaming platforms now we hope to see
you people and I hope I also also hope
to see you at Joey
roses W you sold you sold me big time
and sandwich place down in the low side
of New York Joey roses Joey roses.com
we're open seven days a week I'll see
you there and that's where the After
parties happening on October 28th
boom what's up everybody I am on the
road right now just announce a lot of
dates for my tour they're on sale right
now you can get tickets at Sal volcano
comedy.com I'm coming to Bowling Green
Cincinnati Toledo wils bear Wilmington
mon Savannah and aens Georgia uh I'm
coming to Peoria Rockford and
Springfield Illinois Cedar Rapids duth
Appleton rockchester Davenport and
Elkart Indiana gearing up to film my
special in Chicago uh in December tune
in next week I will give all the
information about this special taping
but until then savoc comedy.com and I'll
see you guys on the road all right I
appreciate that the door yeah babe we're
here for a reason today yeah yeah yeah I
forgot and that reason oh you know what
before did you do you have the one that
me and you did I did I did one with you
yeah you have it right I'll play yeah so
I do social media I got a hidden cameras
in my car and this is one that I did
with s that I just think is amazing wa
yeah I think we got to start it's quick
I think we got to catch the beginning
yeah they're only about 13 to 15 Excuse
Me Miss quick question who do you think
is more attractive me or my
brother I mean I'd like to be sandwich
between the
two have a good day perfect answer how
many views did that get
uh it's probably at 100 million across
all the platforms I don't even know you
could take my 10 years of television and
everything I've ever done and add it up
it's not 100 million yeah it's pretty
it's pretty insane wild crazy dude you
know what it is it's like it's so easy
to share it's like Feelgood funny just
it's like I liken it to like you know
when you check out the grocery store you
go oh I'm gonna get that oh I'm gonna
get that it's just Feelgood ages 8 to 80
and I edit it like that where it's just
like oh I got to share that I got to
share that stocking stuff I got to share
that that's F how do you hide a camera
that's able to
capture the other car so I have um
GoPros right um all GoPros in the car
all rigged up and you don't have to tell
that woman hey so um what uh everything
no one's ever said out of 750 videos I
think I've had four people say hey do
you mind taking that down and I take it
down then I go oh it's already done but
um most of the time I'll go hey I do
social media if you want some comedy
tickets and they go oh great and here's
my name so I I get them at the next
light oh you okay so you go back to that
lady yeah I'll see you at the next
that's great man that's great yeah it's
just like happy Feelgood and also it's
always yes and I make them feel good I
never make them look worse right so
nobody cares but 100 million views yeah
it's pretty 100 million it's it's it's
so I I'll do you one better if you put
together everything I've ever done
everything I ever will
do
right everything I've ever done plus
everything I ever will do plus also
everything me and my family members have
watched we won't hit 100 million
views I don't know I was just so lonely
during the pandemic we were talking
before I was single and lonely I was
like I got to talk to people I can't sit
inside so I just would drive up and down
the same street for 8 10 12 hours making
u-turns and filming that's talking to
people in cars or nobody talking talk
people in cars and they didn't they
weren't like oh you know I got to keep
my window up or no uhuh I did door to-
door sales for 21 years do you have a
mask on no uhuh because you're car to
car you're you're safe yeah yeah well I
agree that you're safe but people were
like so just like you know I think
people were like like hi because people
were so like this so it was like a
welcome break for them to be like hey
yeah okay hey let's I tring next to
someone today at a light all the windows
closed only person in the car driving
mask on it's I didn't know I don't I
mean maybe it's something else I try to
Fathom that I I my guess on when I see
that is this is a person who's immuno
compromised or still wants to mask up
but they don't care enough to take the
mask off in the car put it back on toar
yeah and also they're probably thinking
well the more I touch it the more I'm
going to get germs on it whatever yeah
or maybe that person was doing like
light surgery to someone not Vis visible
to me right S I don't really think the
person was doing light surgery that's
not no we never know you think the guy
did surgery we never know doing surgery
illegally and had to make a quick
getaway yeah what do you think about
illegal surgery I think illegal surgery
is illegal yeah I got to be honest
there's a reason it's not did you ever
go get illegal surgery no but I played
an illegal surgeon on television that
was my whole better call Soul role was
illegal surgery funny I play a doctor on
perfect that is perfect casting you look
like an illegal surgeon thank you thank
you you know you definitely do like
illegal like organ transplants what's
that like say that on Channel maybe I
get a
spin-off 100 million views babe what was
it like when you got you auditioned
right was it was it any callbacks I'm
sure no there was no call back whoa you
got it out of the gate I did an audition
it was the longest audition I ever did
meaning it was 30 minutes right oh to
tape it was to tape no no no I I went in
but we sat there it was the it was the
longest Edition I've ever been in where
the casting director was repeatedly like
once you do it again like this I want
you to do it again like this how many
lines did you have was it like it was a
full scene but she was like she had me
do it so many times I swear to God I
left being
like I didn't why would you got to that
that has to be a good sign though no I
learned that it was she me do it so many
times at one point not when I left
before I left at one point in my head I
was like how bad do I suck at this right
understand like what am I doing wrong
here and then at the end of it she goes
you can take a note
and I was like oh that that was good
that okay wow you know why they do that
and then she was I remember she goes uh
she goes uh I go I looked at her wall
like we we were getting along and I
looked at her wall and and I realized
she was casting Gotham was before the
Gotham show came out and I was so
excited about Gotham yeah and I was like
you're casting Gotham and she's like yes
you didn't see any of this and I was
like okay I won't I won't I was like is
it cool and she's like like it's kind to
it's going to be what was the call like
and I'll ask you the same cuz you were
on the Sons of Anarchy for you it was
one it was two years yeah and you were
on first so the call when I got it yeah
this is what happened yeah this is so
crazy I was headlining at um Flappers in
Burbank in Broad Ripple well that's
crackers crackers yeah that's what I was
said crackers I was headlining that
weekend at Flappers and
Burbank and and it was the I was out in
the lobby in between the two shows on
Saturday and I was waiting to do the
second show and this guy came up and I
had Pat Walsh with me he came to the
show and he had already gone in to to
have a drink or or to sit down I mean
and I was standing out in the bar
area and this guy came up to me and I
didn't know him and he goes Hey Joe and
I go hey man what's up and he goes my
name's Tom I go hey he delivered it in
person I go he goes he goes I go what's
going on and he goes he goes uh I work
for Better Call Saul and I
go or he goes he goes I'm an EP on
Better Call Saul what you know and I go
hi and he goes we loved your audition
and I go he was just randomly in the
audience no he was coming to see me wow
he's coming to watch the show and I was
like wait and you came you're coming to
the show and he's like yeah yeah oh so
to further watch you or no he just was
like yeah I'm coming to the show and he
goes you were great you're gonna get the
part you're either gonna get that part
or Another Part you didn't hear that
from me but you're gonna get one of the
two parts wow what did you what did you
what did you say what your response I
just was like Jesus dude I don't I don't
know what to say like like and he was
like I was like that's oh my God can I
get you anything like you know and he's
like no dude no you have a good show I'm
here to hang out I'm how was the show
killer you killed I went up to Pat and I
go I need you to come with me right now
and I brought him back to the green room
and I go I'm freaking out right now that
was the guy from I'm not supposed to
even talk that I audition but I have to
tell somebody and I told him and he's
like dude that's great mle like
have a good time and I had a killer
show and uh and then but I didn't hear
anything still oh wow and then the next
like the next week yeah my friend cat
was doing makeup on the
show and she texted me and goes I can't
wait to see you in New
Mexico and then I called my manager and
I was like I I I got it I have it I
think I have it right and uh
and my manager then my agent called me
and she's like you did get it that your
friend wasn't supposed to say that to
you w but she did um but anyway um yeah
that's that's how I found out yeah yeah
crazy about you it's amazing you
remember exactly where you were I was
actually in theor office really I was in
the chiropractor's office and I just
left still like in the little waiting
room and then I sat down and I'm like by
the way this was just a reoccurring I
think I had like a couple lines here or
there like here's your paperwork but I
was like I I made it oh my God I made it
you know but that show was already a
huge hit when I went on it so season six
and seven and I just sat down there I
was like yo this is wow like how many
people move to LA or wherever and never
get a one chance dude yeah it's it's
it's an incredible thing man and it's
that is how you feel you're just like
wow then do you your pants before
the scene starts like I I can't be the
one to F this up my very first scene I
was on the side of a mountain it was a
night shoot they had like a fake Moon
like to provide light and everything and
I was in the whole cop outfit and there
was a car like flipped over thing and
and they action and I and I and I just
forgot my line oh the very first scene
Kurt Suter was there and then let's do
it again and then I then from then on I
was like oh but I was nervous as you
know and my line was it was like five
words that's that's the thing too it's
like when it's like that and you're like
I can't mess this up yeah and you're get
in your head even more yeah you know and
uh yeah it's insane oh but but his by
the way Tom Schnell shouts out to Tom
Tom was uh I don't know if I said his
name in the story but that was the guy
that came Tommy he was a yeah an EP on
the show and uh and it was yeah anyway
sorry I didn't mean to take away from
your story no that's great I I always
remember I the the the C my favorite
moment ever in my whole
career between definitely as far as
acting goes uh I haven't done a ton but
I've gotten to do a lot of cool stuff
and I'm very lucky uh
but uh the the coolest thing was the
second time I was there not the first
time Jonathan Banks took me aside and
goes oh he's aw and he goes uh he goes
you want to run lines you want to go
rehearse and I'm like yeah and we went
into his trailer and we hung out and he
goes he goes I want to tell you
something man he goes you're good so if
you need another take today you ask for
it don't get scared man cuz I know how
this is dude I know that this is like a
new thing that's so cool of to do that
so cool wow it was so cool in a
beautiful moment oh God I'm going to get
teary if I say this I'm going to try not
to the last the last time I saw him was
the last time I you know he didn't die
or
anything I don't be like that just mean
the last time I saw him when I was there
was the last time I was shooting we went
out and got dinner the night before I
had to shoot and I go listen man I don't
know when I'm going to see you again
because I don't live in LA anymore and
this is it this is the last season I
don't know if I'll be back and I said uh
and I go I go but I go I just want you
to know I learned more
uh I learned more uh standing across
from you as an actor than I ever learned
in a class and wow he like he got got
teary it was a beautiful wow it was
like a really really nice co and I meant
it cuz I'd said it to everybody so many
people had said what's it like what's it
like and I would always say I've learned
more standing across from that guy than
I could have ever learned in any class
like I go what did you what did you like
what like give me an example of
something you gleaned from him that like
is it is it just just observing him
change Nuance or like did he do did did
they does he every take differently or
is it like what what did you no he like
he he taught me like the importance of
confidence mhm not arrogance those are
two different things right uh he talk
like when they go acting's all in the
eyes he's guy I got it finally with him
I was like oh that's what they mean when
they say that okay cuz the guy was like
a statue he doesn't move at
least in that character I mean he he
like wouldn't move and and and you were
like almost like physically backing away
from him during the scenes because he's
like so intense wow and um and and then
also too just
just professional like
1,000% professional he told me a story
once where he said a a director said I
want you to cry in this take he goes if
that happens it'll happen I'm not going
to make that H I was like that's oh like
that's a real actor man that's a guy
that's like I'm in it and this is I'm
going to give you the truth I just
learned I just learn you imagine the
director like I need you to do something
like maybe yeah but he's the one on
screen so if it's not authentic people
going to notice you know yeah he just
was like I'm not going to make that I'm
not going to force it in that direction
if it comes out that way then great and
but he was but he was like uh just also
too like you know dude I I studied
theater in college and and and uh I've
I've I've done enough TV at this point
that I'm like you meet a lot of and just
even on
auditions right it's a hammy thing like
acting can be very hammy yeah yeah and
you know just just standing ACR not to
say that I didn't learn with the other
people I worked with there too but I
worked with him the most and and he
really resonated with me and he just was
like
um he didn't um he
just he just gave it what it needed that
was it there was never more there was
never it was never about him he was able
to yeah right right yeah he's like a guy
in a this a guy he's 60 years in the
business or whatever it is and he he
knows like this is not about me this is
about a scene right you know what I mean
yeah that's cool man that's awesome it's
why like in the and I'll shut up after
this cuz I want to talk to you
sorry but it's why I'm I admir
what would St Peter uh ask you when you
get to the Pearly
Gates but it's what I admired so much
about Theo you know that yeah it's what
I admired so much about the Nero and the
Irishman was I was watching him and I
was like this guy is the biggest actor
that has ever lived and he is doing a
movie where every other actor is pushing
him around and he knows that's what this
character is about it is not about him
getting to get his dairo time on screen
did you like it I loved it I think it's
a masterpiece I remember watching it and
liking uh I liked it but uh I love it I
that's another watch with that it was
like ah but I you know what I'm I wanted
young you know you know that's I wanted
what you were talk the opposite what
you're talking about I wanted dairo to
be dairo yeah you know I guess the old
school pety talked about in the behind
the scenes he goes he goes Marty he
calls him Marty I don't I never met the
guy but he's like Marty just kept
keeping like suppressing my he was like
you're you never Flinch and he talks
about the scene when Pacino's screaming
at him at the ball and he's like he said
he was going to score sesy in between
takes he's like come on like I wouldn't
this guy's given it to me and he's like
that's not who this guy is you don't
Flinch you never show your hand or
whatever so peshi was talking about how
it was such a different experience for
him for p to fly off the handle and do
peshy yeah they said they added I
went I went to an early screening and we
got to do the Q&A with the writer which
was awesome he said they added the scene
where peshi walks in covered in blood
because the character is so
reserved and almost benevolent
throughout the movie he goes we needed
something to show you that he's
dangerous okay so he's like we just
added this scene where he walks in
covered in blood and you realize this
guy's like I got to give another watch
you know something else I've been
meaning to watch again Copland you
remember Copland one of the best movies
of all time wait who was in was that it
was everybody yeah was that was
everybody was in it right it was like
Sylvester Sylvester Bruce Willis was
that it no it's dairo I remember
Sylvester Stone Stone Le Stallone Dao
Leota K more than that though um Michael
Rapaport but dude Josh when you said the
reason you're disappointed in Irishman
because you weren't getting yeah the qu
the violence stere stereotyp what
Copland you are getting
DeNiro like the most hammy awesome dairo
like he's doing all the like all that y
like he's yelling all that Leota plays a
cokehead he's off the meter through the
whole movie Rapaport is totally like you
guys are crazy like like that kind of
is is
like like yelling Kel they are all so
them through like Garo is like everybody
in this thing you got to watch Copland
dude that movie is awesome I have no
recollection of it I want to watch this
we'll do it for my birthday yeah we'll
watch it we'll watch it tomorrow yeah
you guys should I just do it likef I go
for my birthday I want to watch it such
a fun watch wait I know we got a battle
but I wanted to hear more I talked
so much about my dumb thing you what was
your thing with Sons of Anarchy like
that you know what was your big moment
where you were like wow this is really
like this was a CH game changer for me
honestly when I went in they they they
wanted the cop to be kind of a jerk you
know like a real real bad person just
kind of deep I just thought of my
stepfather oh wow cuz I at that time I
still had so much anger for him you have
him to thank for your success and I'm
Sil I'm goofy like you see me on stage
I'm goofy but I was like I just did that
and after the oh by the way it was great
when I walked the guy running the camera
was a comic he just happened to do
casting and I was like hey Chris hey and
I completely forgot cuz I get real
nervous before like I want before I did
this podcast I wanted to kill myself
that's great before anything before I go
on stage I want to kill myself and then
I'm fine yeah but the guy and so I
auditioned and uh and afterwards uh the
cast goes wow you're really good at
being mean and I'm like thanks like you
know what I mean like I was that's great
I actually just just remember this
second it's four was four lines or
something like that but I I did an
audition for the Irishman you did yeah
and I believe the scene was not in the
ended up not being in the movie was
there a scene where a guy pissed his
pants no he was a like a a guy I was in
it was dairo and and this guy and dairo
is kind of thre like threatening him and
he scares him so bad that when he's
talking to me he pisses his pants no I
would I wish that scene wasn't it that
would be I went in for that and I was
like all right look I don't know you
know did you ever take acting classes or
anything no no no and so I just went in
and I think I did my hair and I wore
certain clothes to kind of match what I
thought it would be and I went in I'm
like look it's that's it is it is what
it is it's three or four lines I don't
really care but I was still nervous and
then I uh I had them memorized and I had
like you know the different ways I was
going to approach it or whatever and I
went in there and there's this woman
that cast all his movies it was the
woman that cast all his movies whatever
her name is she's sweet lady W and um
the first take I I was doing it I got to
a place where I was really confident and
how I was rehearsing it and then of
course the first take was terrible it
was terrible and then you know we did
another take and another take and then
she's talking to me and she comes she's
just talking to me now she's like now
she comes in front of the camera and
she's just like oh yeah know cuz we knew
someone in common and then she was
asking about a couple things and and I
told her in on the show Jokers I had to
piss my pants for real in a scene and so
we were like talking about that and then
in the middle of talking about that she
was like asked me a question about that
and then she just went and she just she
just started with the lines like she was
right in my face and in the middle of
talking to me I was like that's great
yeah and then I just like and I just was
like and then I did the I did the lines
but it was probably terrible that's
great though that's wild that that's I
love hearing about how directors
audition actors yeah you know what I
mean yeah cuz like like I think
what all right folks game time I love
game time why cuz I hate planning months
in advance or even weeks in advance for
events I may be able to go to my
schedule changes so much I like to go at
the last minute and when you go at the
last minute you don't want it to be
stressful so buying tickets for your
favorite events is made very easy
through game time it's an easy way to
get those tickets affordably the best
deals possible right up until the day of
the event for sports comedy music
whatever it is you want to go to uh
they've got images of seat views and
again lowest price guarantee event
cancellation protection couple Taps yes
it's great it's great oh and one other
thing the tickets are sent directly to
your phone so you're not digging through
emails when you get up inline which I've
done a million times and if you find a
more affordable ticket in the same row
and same section you're in game time
will refund you 100 or credit you excuse
me game time will credit you 110% of the
difference so snag the tickets without
the stress with Game Time download the
game time app create
use code taste buds for $20 off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code tastebuds for
$20 off download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price guaranteed
taste buds is sponsored by betterhelp I
love betterhelp I'm a user of betterhelp
I'm proud that they are one of the
sponsors on this podcast sometimes in
life you're faced with tough choices we
all are and the path forward isn't
always clear sometimes the problem
itself can become the roadblock and
getting to the solution for that problem
starts to become a very very convoluted
process and it could be whether you're
dealing with decisions based uh around
your career or or regarding your
relationships or anything else whatever
it is my point is is therapy can really
help you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life
that's why I like better help uh I have
benefited greatly from therapy in my
life and I find that when I'm not in the
practice of utilizing it uh again the
problems become insurmountable and the
solutions become elusive when I'm in
therapy I got a clear lens over the eyes
I see things for what they are I'm able
to approach them with the clear mindset
that I need better help helps me with
that if you're thinking of trying
therapy starting therapy give better
help a try I I'm telling you it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient it's flexible and it's suited
to your schedule you fill out a brief
questionnaire you get matched with a a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists at any time at no additional
charge that's really really good trust
me uh anyway let therapy be your map
with betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds today and get 10% off your
first month that's betterhelp
hp.com
tastebuds Woody Allen had some has oh no
it was Larry David has like a thing
where like if you audition for
curb they're they're like you're going
to walk in the room and you're going to
be a waiter and you're going to try to
serve Larry food or what like it's
something very weird yeah he's in that
room because Adam Ray I talked to we
know a few people have been on it but
Adam Ray uh he told me he he didn't he
had to run his lines with he got to run
his lines with Larry and then we know a
handful of people on there but I that's
like the golden I think Santino same
thing he ran his lines scar brothers
were on there I'm just trying to think
but I mean that for me is the I didn't
see him on there uh he was on in one of
the more recent Seasons oh no that's
right no yeah yeah the cup of joe thing
or now I remember yeah Santino is a a
dope actor great I'm telling you like I
can't wait till the world sees his
genius he's like Kristoff Waltz when he
he delivers the Lions I love him yeah I
was with him all weekend in Austin we
hung out all weekend that dude is and we
were breaking balls oh I love that kid I
wish he lived on the East Coast he did
this is this is true we we're we're in a
hotel one day and we're hanging out in
the pool the pool table room and a guy
came in and said guys this is um we have
this reserved for a wedding reception so
have fun whatever but we'll just need
you to clear out when we say the word
and Andrew goes okay it's just me and
Andrew and his buddy and Andrew goes
okay no problem and he goes by the way
love your stuff you're really funny man
to Andrew and then he turned to me and
he goes thanks for being cool and he
walked out and I go I mean it kind of
hurts he recognized you doesn't
recognize me and Andrew goes I'm more
famous than you well
what are you what are you confused about
right he starts doing this thing and I
go can you stop just stop and he goes
what do you not like the truth like and
he's dude he's really going into it and
I go I don't like this bit at all that
we're doing right now and I go can I
tell you something and he started
laughing I go can I tell you something I
go you're too good of an actor to do
bits that are that mean because it's way
too real it's like it just gets whether
it's true or not it just gets too yeah
and he's like all right all right it's
always fun on his PO or when he comes on
our pod because it's so fun going back
and forth with him he's the best he's
the best and Heart of Gold yeah Heart of
Gold there you go if you if you if
you're watching and we know that you are
Santini Santini the great Santini all
right we got to get to this battle all
right it's a breakfast battle uh you
came in hot saying you hate pancakes hey
pancakes this is pretty crazy no it's
not insane I can back it up honestly I
think the first person I've ever met
that doesn't like pancakes I mean I
argued against pancakes versus I think
it was waffles in this because there are
things I don't like about pancakes but I
don't hate pancakes what don't you like
about
pancakes well I
mean sometimes it just feels like a
whole lot of the same exact thing just
bread wait wait wait let's do the chant
ready time to b a t t l e
buds you missed that one too I missed it
again yeah wait you're saying pancakes
are just bread is that what you just
bread and then you put syrup on it and
it's the same thing bite after bite
after bite I I've had some pancakes that
changed my life too though I'm saying no
I new for you pal what cuz the niceties
are gone now now we're in the battle I
got news for you pal any food you eat is
the same thing bite after bite that's
how Food Works eggs Benedict's the same
thing bite after bite too yeah but it's
BL that's a very good point because you
eat a stack of it there's not many
things you eat a stack of yeah I mean
you got some balls you play that either
way you could play that either way it's
like I don't think I like to eat a stack
of the same food but then why is it
served as a stack because people want
that much of it no it's because they're
cheap and they're trying to rip you off
that's why no no no no when you get
pancak there's a reason why when you go
to a breakfast place pancakes are a
barometer food they're a barometer food
meaning you taste them and you know how
how good the rest of the place is people
will no people will say how are the
pancakes oh my god dude okay trust me
they because people that make them wrong
they suck and they it's we talked about
Seinfeld a lot last episode it's say
line on Seinfeld when they bring their
own syrup to the diner yeah and Grammer
goes pancakes were excellent today like
it is a
food where you go these guys know the
pan they trust me dude get the there's a
diner I think it's called Sunshine Diner
it's right near my apartment I for prove
it they have
pancakes uh Nick Simmons son of the
great Jean Simmons of Kiss who's a dear
friend of mine Nick not Jean never met
Jean no Nick anyway
Nick Nick's a big comedy fan for good
friends he likes the podcast anyway what
yeah he he texted me for three weeks
going did you go get those pancakes yet
and I finally went and I I text him I go
dude my mind is blown this is one of the
best things I've ever had in my life
I'll tell you right now I know the best
pancakes I've ever had Bar None
immediately where it was at a place
that's now called Shuka I think it's
down by Prince and 6th Avenue or
something like that it was called 100
acres at the time and they did a
fantastic brunch and uh they did a
orange zest racotta pancake that was
Fluffy and moist and they topped it with
fresh whipped cream and strawberries and
it was so good that I asked the staff I
would go there all the time with them
and I asked the staff to ask them the
chef to give me the recipe and he did
but he gave it to me in the portions of
what they make for the restaurant and I
was never able to I gave it to my lady
there who's a great cook and I was never
she was never able to really recreate
exactly because you know what I mean
you'd have to make it so many times but
I dream about them because they changed
to a different restaurant now I can
never have I can tell you something side
note you're not going to change your
mind about pancakes but I think pancakes
are one of the only food that actually
can be ordered as a side and a main
course that's a great observation but
you're not going to change my mind that
is that is a good another food now you
go to IHOP get a side you can get a side
of eggs with your pancakes or a side of
pancakes with your eggs no you can't get
a side you cannot get a side of eggs
with your pancakes brother I did it I
did it in Austin not four mornings ago I
I ordered I got pancakes for breakfast
eggs feels like an two main no I didn't
I said I said I want I want a side of
eggs I don't want a whole egg Entre she
goes you want one egg I go yeah exactly
yeah it feels more like an addition to
the plate to me than a side yeah you
went off book that's not they did
something just texted me what is going
on said Up Is Down left is right what is
going on what does he say hold on please
let it be something
mean oh no he's asking me something
about something else oh that was that
was was titilating it was a heartfelt
yeah it was a hard fil but wait P you're
right but wait can I say a negative
about both these
Foods both these Foods we only talk
about the the egg Benedict is who what
you're defending no I'm defending Pegg
I'm defending the egg Benedict egg
Benedict right right you like the eggs
benedict don't like the pancakes I'll
say I'll say a negative about both Foods
these are both Foods where if you don't
get them right off the grill you you got
problems yeah yeah you got to both these
foods have a shelf life pancakes will
just become dry and cold and crumbly and
shitty and eggs benedict it is not long
before that turns into a like a hockey
puck yeah but pancakes get uh get worse
quicker you can leave the benedict for
longer that's that's that's absolutely
wrong you think that you can leave Ben
about that I think that that's
absolutely wrong no because have you
tell you talk the butter and syrup's on
it already no I'm just talking pancakes
no well butter and syrup on it the clock
is really ticking but I'm say I have
look at that look at that's what
Benedict looked like most of the time it
goes to that plasticky look so fast that
you're like what happened yeah but it
makes me feel rich when I eat it every
time I eat Ed in the name is it in the
name just everything is it like saying
like uh like Duck laange or clam's
Casino all of it and more all of it more
I think that that point is a problem
with your life yeah and not applicable
as a I mean you're driving up and down
the street by yourself and piss I'm not
surprised like Rich I'm sleeping in
urine it's not piss it's urine it's a
higher class of piss what an I
sleep in urine I I I will say something
about the egg Benedict okay I go
exloring
I can't stand the Ben by the way I don't
know what that is yeah I don't know what
it is what's an eggs Flor I do no holays
it's just it's just a a poach tag on an
English muffin top with some steamed
spinach or sauteed spinach and and they
do the hollay but I don't want the
Holliday why don't you want the H and
also I might might I might I might might
put on a piece of little bacon on there
but I don't like holidays holidays is
horrific I've I've never eaten holidays
I I've said no holidays they brought it
holidays I have to send it back it's not
good for you holays it's disgusting
Turles it's it's it's it's too thick and
Rich it it dominates the whole plate
here's what I don't like about holiday
sauce it looks like it's going to taste
like six other sauces that it doesn't
taste like I see holiday sauce I think
it's going to taste like sausage gravy
it doesn't I see it I think it's going
to taste like a sweet cream almost like
a Cinnabon flavor it doesn't I think
it's going to taste like mayonnaise it
doesn't I don't know what the hell it's
going to tast look at though it doesn't
look good does hollay sauce live
anywhere except on the Benedict that's a
good question my friend yes it does
because I've seen it poured on asparagus
in
restaurants yeah I've seen like I've
seen like like asparagus or broccoli and
a fancy restaurant right I I don't yeah
it's a fancy restaurant I would say a
place that thinks it's fancy but maybe
it's a little not fancy yeah I'd say
acier spot is yeah that's why I like the
Benedict holiday sauce is a classic
creamy sauce I don't like creamy sauces
I love creamy sauce I don't care what
we're talking about eggs pasta whatever
can I see what it is what it is I like a
creamy sauce on a chicken but that's
about it just takes five minutes in a
blender but what is it it's like isn't
it like jump pimp click jump go back
click where it says jump to recipe right
at the
top okay uh okay so you got three egg
yolks yeah some lemon juice not too bad
so far some Dijon mustard
okay4 tablesp of salt can you scroll him
cayenne pepper what half a cup of
unsalted butter well that doesn't make
any sense at all why well first of all
let me tell you put an egg on top of egg
that's what I just was about to say that
just blew me away yeah I don't know if I
realized that egg holidays was made of
egg and you're putting three egg yolks
over two other eggs well look how many
ingredients are in there with pancakes
you got a pan and a cake and that's it
feels wrong it feels great pancakes rer
a little more complicated than you think
dude you're dealing with baking soda
baking flour or powder you're dealing
with with a flour you're dealing with
sometimes a cinnamon some vanilla
extract and a chef who has to put it
together which means it's done by a
professional pancakes you can do it you
can do it no I'm saying everything I
just have you ever tried to make
pancakes it is no walk in the
[Music]
park I can just get just his head it is
no walk in the park the way you deliver
that was I don't even know what all
right can we clip it clip it that was
amazing I I meant it with all my heart I
know do you know I want your face I
wanted a meme I just want to put it out
with no context into the world have you
ever tried to make pancakes it's no walk
in the park I have I mean it I have said
things to pancakes are easy to make bro
that I have not said to my worst enemy
when I'm making it's harder to make an
eggs benedict than it is to make
pancakes I'm not saying poach an egg I'm
not saying it's not hard to do I'm
saying pancakes you got it's a
frustrating and I don't cook so I'm not
on the same pancakes did you forget but
I'm still I'm still I'm stilles he goes
back and for dude I'm telling you dude
with pancakes if you don't have the
right like evenly heated Grill top if
dude you flip it too early it doesn't
have the right amount of baking I forget
which one makes it rise properly soda or
flour but whatever you don't have enough
of that in there it can be very
frustrating one side gets burnt the
other side doesn't you ever flip a
pancake and it doesn't work and you're
that's why Uncle Buck when he's going I
get that it's giant you should see the
to couldn't get through the door but
he's going this is where the men are
separated for the boys cuz flipping a
Pake is nerve-wracking okay I get that
but I will say you know what though
pancakes and I don't like to I don't
really cook I don't but I do pancakes
are fun to make I love where you pour it
in and you try to get like you know you
don't want the circles to touch each
other and you want to make make them the
perfect like thickness not too thin I
like the way they look I like flipping
them the process of making pancakes I
love but can I can I register one more
gripe with the
Benedict I I'm I don't love Canadian
bacon oh I love Canadian bacon ham
Canadian styleon call bacon it's just
like Canadian three words Canadian
grilled ham on there I can't go with you
on that to me ham is always King over
bacon ham and cheese is one of my two
favorite s don't care that they're
calling ham Canadian bacon I like that
I'm getting ham with my eggs ham and
eggs is a is a classic it's to greasy
between the cream and bacon is way
greasier I think the tast Canadian bacon
know why they I'm sorry not to go off
top why do they call it Canadian bacon
as opposed to just bacon I think it is
cured a bit differently it also only
Canadian bacon only comes in disc form
for some reason so just said it as free
healthcare that was his joke to me he
goes to bacon as free healthcare oh is
I'm sorry no no don't but I am asking
have you ever seen Canadian bacon
outside of disc for no and this is what
I'm saying it feels just like a big
scam like and what do what does the
Canadian bacon look like before it's
sliced it just looks like
baloney how is that bacon it's magical
is a pig
Canadian how what's type of meat the two
kinds of bacon come from different parts
of the animal Canadian bacon comes from
the back while American bacon comes from
the Bell therefore Canadian American
bacon have different textures and fat
content Canadian bacon is a lean cut
while American bacon is fatter so the B
you're eating a pig back by the way side
note Canadian bacon is that what's used
on an Egg
McMuffin it is and that's why I don't
get
it but I I still
they they they if I actually do I'm not
trying to make a St about McDonald's I
would like to go to the McDonald's site
I don't think it's described as Canadian
bacon with it's not but we know what it
is and I'll say another thing that just
told me pimp though that just told me
the difference between the two why is it
called
Canadian uh why is it called Canadian I
assume that it is a slightly different
cut of ham and it's cured a bit
differently but why is it called
Canadian I'm I'm assuming it's a
Canadian thing that they do but do you
see how much more interesting this
conversation is than
pancakes no there it is there it is I
don't product was first shipped imported
from Toronto to New York City okay so
Toronto bacon doesn't have the same ring
to it
I think Toronto bacon has a nice ring
though Theon ton Canadian
toron Canadian Canadian bacon hey s
better tomorrow do you mind if you and I
go out and get some Toronto bacon I do
you can you buy it in the store oh go
get some Toronto BAC I only only diners
have access to no I've seen Canadian
bacon but it's
like these products these breakfast
meats it's it becomes weird because you
got your grilling sausage in one section
you got your breakfast sausage in
another right you got your hot dogs over
here but your balone over there yeah you
got this bacon here but I feel like
Canadian bacon might be in with where
the ham is like with but the dinner ham
not the lunch meat ham it's it's so
basically is wild to Big processed Meats
to the industry uh these are some viable
gripes that you have here they're not
gri it's just it's just hard to find at
all that's all you know like you could
easily go into a store and go they don't
have one of those things and they do
have it you just weren't look it in the
right place I feel like holiday sauce is
like chicken throw up or
something there is a vomity look to it
it's weird to liquefy the egg and then
pour it over the solid
egg it's like anything else what if you
put chicken in a blender and liquify and
pour it over your chicken it's just so
damn bad for you put it on the side why
not put it on the side you got a side of
uh of egg get aide of Hond I thought it
was going to say way worse though it was
just eggs it's like egg salt and like
mustard and dude it was eggs butter oh
butter lemon but it's so funny cuz those
things you're naming like butter lemon
and salt I'm like yes give me all of it
I don't know what happens in there
between I'm telling you I am telling you
what it is about holay sauce that I
believe you don't well there's also
lemon injected into that which is an odd
addition lemon and egg don't go I don't
like the lemon I got to be honest with
you I don't want to cross boundaries but
I do not like the lemon in there that's
why I get the Holland on the side and I
only dip it in or I dip the fork and
then I cut and then that's the way to do
it anyway you can't smother it
but what made your what make what makes
this is what I want from you though
right now because we haven't gotten it
what
makes what the hell is it eggs benedict
your favorite bre you said this is your
favorite breakfast food I think two
things I think one I like the salt
content and then also it makes me feel
rich it makes me feel like what a
country club oh yeah I feel rich right
right that's why is the bottom an
English muffin Bottom's an English
muffin yeah okay yeah and it's butter
but see I like Rockefeller that's a good
one kind of I like to feel disgusting
after I eat I like to feel like a
glutton after I eat this is this is up
there with oysters Rockefeller where
I've never seen it in a truly fancy
restaurant I've only seen it in
restaurants that are you think might be
fancy but they're not really by the way
I don't even know what Oysters
Rockefeller is I was going along with
with like bacon and I think cheese and
stuff just bake like kind of fancy
anything that's fancy I like but I do
have that addictive like I work out at
the gym and I I eat hor I had I had
McDonald's last night before the gym
today well it got
mentioned I did but I ordered it with no
bun I ordered the Big Mac with no bun so
I feel what they how do they give it to
you they literally brought a uh like a
little plastic tray and it was all the
ingredients no pickles cuz I don't like
pickles and then it wasn't a lettuce bun
nope no you just got beef stacked I just
said I didn't want a bun I thought it
was going to be lettuce and it end up
just being the meat and the cheese and
all that stuff they give you a knife of
fork no I ate it in my oh I ate it in
the urine bed I ate it in the urine bed
just realized that I was sitting the
only that would be more disgusting if
that was holiday thing I was sitting
right on the urine with a towel eating
McDonald's yeah I'll say one one parting
thing about the eggs benedict oh the
hollidays I should say I I don't like
Mayo I only can have Mayo on a on a ham
and cheese sandwich and it's got to be
moderate and that's it and I feel like
hollidays is like Mayo's cousin what do
you get a be on a BLT do you get mayo no
you're so boring you're so boring how
can you get a BLT with no mayo that's
all that's literally the fun part of the
BLT I have the BLT no mayo that's bat
do it's a good act out yeah that's
bat why that's bad I thank you
that's crazy thank you I know you don't
need it but a BL it's delicious without
it I get the juice from the tomato No
it's not about the juice it's the The
BLT hinges on the Mayo it's like you
need you need it the moistening of that
toast I don't like anything that you
slather you don't have to butter I tell
them I tell them light on the Mayo you
don't have to get a it doesn't I don't
like if it's dripping out but it add see
it on a burger oh my God who eats it on
a burger you yeah that's not that's
telling you do you eat on a burger Mayo
on a burger Mayo on a Burg sometimes a
light a little bit of light mayo on it
mayo and ketchup but then you're masing
it I Wendy's introduced me to the May on
the burger and I I like it it's amazing
the do you like the Baconator the
Wendy's bacon ater of course oh it's the
best thing in the world and you feel
like a glutton after you eat it it's the
same thing with eggs benedict I'm
telling you well I think that it's safe
to say just if I'm a a betting man I
could say because pancakes are a Domin
dominant force in breakfast foods I
think that it's going to
win handily over eggs benedict we're
going to go to the uh the phones really
really quick pimp really really quick
let's see what these people are saying
today children eat pancakes adults eat
egg bennies I'll tell you one thing I
don't like when they call them bennies I
don't like I hate that takes the the the
the prestige out of it an egg Benny yeah
I hate the statement so much of adults
do this children do that I hate that I
don't know why it bothers me so much com
in strong here eggs benedict is the best
breakfast there is pancakes are good but
just fluffy bread whoo yes anyone who
chooses pancakes or eggs benedict just
has never had breakfast at any
restaurant besides a Denny's type place
oh stop it eggs benedict are the most
ger the most geriatric food Choice all
right no because you can't have it as
geriatric it's too much sodium I love me
some pancakes but an eggs benedict makes
me feel a bit more sophisticated whoa
I'm telling you I'm right in line with
this I've rearch I've done research this
is what this is what trashy people think
is fancy you're trash first of all I
always sleep in the finest urine beds
okay so don't call me trash in the grand
jizz of it all pancakes have less
variety than Benedicts you can make them
Seafood meat veggie anything there's a
lot of variety of pancakes yeah let see
what Jack says this is like there's not
a lot ofet P drunk cousin you just add
things to it pancakes all day I don't
maybe I'm wrong I thought it was going
to be like a a pretty dominant win but
let's go to the phones here let's go to
the Humble Pie drum roll pimpy roll out
that pie chart here 6,000 votes he's
going
pancakes oh you know what honestly X
Benedict probably did a little better
than I even thought it was going to yeah
well given the comments I thought we
were going to lose yeah I thought it was
be closer actually right pancakes uh
takes the win 70.9% to 29.1% to eggs
benedict I uh I like the conversation
though about the foods I did I I we had
a pleasant dialogue about both Foods and
I uh my takeaway was that I I really
enjoyed it I'm overly excited that I had
people agree with me I feel I feel
Vindicated I feel happy like but weirdly
it wasn't a blowout yeah I I feel all
right I feel like I I I have some
brethren out there that I can go to a
country club and eat and feel richer
than I am we should try to we should try
to put together a battle that we think
will be 100% to 0% and see if we can get
it you have he a Google
Flack no it's when you Google two words
together and there's no results I know
what one side of that battle is I don't
want to say it right now okay but I want
us to make a note of it okay because I'm
almost positive I know what one side of
that battle okay okay babe uh plug
anything you need to plug right to the
folks I'll be at the Hollywood improv
headlining in the lab on August 30th and
then the weekend before I don't know
when this drops I'll be in San Diego
with ismo at uh the American Comedy
Company and then just Josh Nasser n
across all platforms yeah it's I think
it's dropped to 20 4th I think yep so
that's in time for that and we just Reed
on the taste buds Merch this is the last
time we were reupping so if you never
got tastebuds merch get it now cuz once
this sells out we are moving away you
never get this shirt again I get
compliments on this shirt all the time
by the way I know I got to get one I
don't have one you don't have this shirt
no what's wrong with you I don't know I
don't have it I don't know why I don't
have I I have it's Behavior I also
didn't I don't think I took I took the
socks but I don't know if I took any
t-shirt merch cuz I felt weird walking
around with a t-shirt on of my myself
yeah the socks you can push down and
they just kind of yeah but not it's
silly silly goose stuff and thank you by
the way for wearing one of my merch oh I
forgot to tell you I went to tone Bell
what shout outs to tone Bell happy
birthday buddy I went to tone Bell's
birthday party in Austin on Saturday
night dude I got so many compliments on
this shirt really people were like yo
that shirt's good man that's a cool
shirt oh man yeah it got tons of
compliments oh cool I yeah makes you
feel good yeah it look good in it quick
question that to at s comedy.com get all
that Mar is that the same shirt that you
wore that night did you wash
it yes okay yes I did I did a load of
laundry before I left Austin staying
with my buddy Gom shouts out to
Gom I'm not above wearing a t-shirt if I
don't sweat and I've only worn a small
amount of time I fold that right back up
I keep it on top of the dresser not back
in but I know that's there for another
quick use if I need it this had to be
wased it was
107° every day that I was there it was
crazy uh anyway people love the shirt
absolutely well uh yeah so I
still no we yeah yeah we still love you
buddy you say now I love you too I love
you
too
t the M the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man they coming